[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys John with off-grid homesteading
welcome to a new installment of fixing
our water pump at the lower cistern
hopefully this will be the final fix
I've been using a shurflo diaphragm pump
for the first year and a half the
diaphragm pumps work great they can
actually pump up to about you know
siphoning about seven feet of pressure
and then pump it up the lines that are
going up to our upper cistern challenges
when it gets cold that box gets real
cold the parts and starts start freezing
and the components in there start
failing that failed last a little bit
after last winter and the components are
failing again so it's now time to take
this aquamarine made 24 volt DC pump
four amps max 100 foot maximum
submersible 100 foot and it'll do 1.6
gallons per minute but this is the one
of those pumps you'll find on Amazon
I'll put a link to this
I think it was about $90 I ended up
getting one the top was cracked the
company was real good they ended up
sending me another one took forever to
get it and then when I finally call this
air where the heck's my cap they just
went ahead and shipped me another unit
and then a few days later the caps came
in so I have two units now for the price
of one that's being frugal
not cheap so
with this pump I'm going to be
installing it inside the cistern I got
to drill some holes in the side of the
plastic here for the pumping lines going
up into the system but I got to make
sure that the pecs goes all the way to
and inside the top cap here otherwise it
will freeze and it will expand and it'll
correct all the metal parts in between
seem to crack so I have to eliminate all
of the metal pieces unfortunately
there's one metal piece down there so we
got a little weak link of the system
what I should have done is how to
actually run this continual pipe
directly into this tank the first time
so let's go and get started Emma and
apologies for looking like a gimpy old
man I hurt my back last week and it's
been taken its toll this is I think the
heard on Monday today is Thursday so I
can finally at least walk around a
little bit but I still feel pretty stiff
[Applause]
I'm going to show you the flow inside
I've never shown this before that's
coming directly from our develop spring
I'm gonna have a text pipe going from
here to the outside coming down to this
pumping situation here I'm just taking a
regular garden hose which is the one
that seems to fit great here and I'm
going to think I'm going to go ahead and
give me some extra slack here
okay
that's a fairly tight here
I'm going to go ahead and put a float
valve in here just in case I can get it
to work so that if I'm gone and the
thing is pumping up to the top when the
water reaches the bottom it'll turn off
the pump keep it from burning out or
having any issues I'll need to get some
sort of wire tie to keep this in place
the original wire tie copper wire
[Applause]
okay now I'm going to drill the two
holes for the electric wires one for the
float that float switch and the other
one for the pump
[Applause]
okay so what you see in here I've got my
pecs coming in to this point right here
I didn't I really like to go from 3/4
right to the opening I mean now I'm
coming on the output there but this is
already run it's already in the box this
has not broken that has not broken so I
think we're gonna be pretty safe this is
my release the water actually holds the
water from the top of the hill down here
so that if I'm working on the pump I can
shut this off work on it without getting
back sprayed so I'm gonna go and cover
these back up give it a little bit more
protection from winter I need to come
back and put some electrical tape around
all this and make it a little bit better
but this is the positive wire coming off
of the solar panel if this is negative I
am going to go basically positive to
positive to positive negative through
the switch to that so as long as the
float is up it'll get power when the
float goes down to the bottom and we'll
check the pump off remember the white is
positive on the pump and the switch it
doesn't matter which side you put the
connection on it can switch the positive
or it can switch the negative no does
not make a difference doing this to give
me a little bit more slack here I don't
know where my wire
my special wire cutters went so going
back to what works twist those really
good anything here okay
yeah strip these now positive to
positive it's gonna even see if I can
hear the pump running for a second
I feel voltage all right so from here
[Applause]
and I had this setup for my other setup
there you go now we got voltage right
there I had this set up for a stop
switch up top so with the black wire
that's negative so right now with this
one
while the float is up it cuts the power
and when the float is down it starts it
so we need it the other way around when
the float is up the power starts when
the photos down the power stops so this
one is not going to be used
and I'm going to use the opposite wire
because this float switch can work and
open up or open down and the way I could
check that real simple you look close no
spark look here
spark so you got an open circuit I mean
a closed circuit on the red wire right
now and that's what I want I want it on
when the water is up I want it off when
the float drops
[Applause]
okay so I'm gonna put the cap back on
gather up all my crap and take it back
to the top of the hill and then what I
need to come down here and do is fill
these holes up with some silicone keep
any critters and stuff from getting in
there and then as soon as I get a break
in the clouds for a minute I can go up
up there and after a few minutes and we
should be hearing water pumping into the
upper cistern with this new submersible
pump so I'm not gonna have any issues
with priming anymore so I after all the
iterations are the pumps and stuff that
I've used this little orange one that
comes up is like a solar well pump
because we're not
pressurizing a tank up top it goes right
it just drops into the tank from the
techs right into the inlet hole on the
side of the tank that's why you can
actually pump that far because it's uh
it says it'll actually pump a hundred
feet of head up there we're going 50
foot this way and we're not pressurizing
so yeah I've actually had this pump
running the I had the other pump running
at the pond and it pumped from the pond
all the way to the top of the hill so I
know it works already we just need to
I'm just glad this is done I just don't
have to mess with this thing freezing
any if any more except these connections
here and if these still have an issue
freezing I'll have to insulate them more
and figure out something a better
solution to just put more insulation
around these outlet pipes all right
okay I don't think I've shown the whole
system together in one video for quite
some time I should in the in the
beginning when I was building it so you
can see our setup over here now who's
got our overflow down here returning
back to the stream
here's our overflow this is going down
to our pumping valve and stuff
here's your wires coming in to the edge
of the box coming up and around into
their lids on and this is being
gravity-fed all the way back over there
let me show you my Buried amplifier wire
which is 10 gauge wire all the way back
here 100 feet of it I'll put a link for
that in here as well and I did red and
black wire the red has turned clear and
the black stayed black down here so this
is your positive this is your negative
and these are your oh gosh I figure out
what these MC no what are they these
come off the solar panels so here's the
rating on the solar panel itself so
windy nation this is the ones I used
here I'll put a link in the description
if they're still available or something
comparable
and then basically I built a frame had a
I believe I did a 35 degree now a 33
degree angle and then I wired them in
parallel so you got 12 volts with lots
of the amperage I could actually wire
them in series now give me 24 volts and
I might check that out and see if that
might work better but let's walk over
and see how the spring is doing I know
my battery's running low yeah it's
working pretty good so here's my
overflow
[Applause]
my overflow
and you can see we're not having
very little leakage right there where we
did all the all the work before this is
something off right off the top that's
coming off the other edge and then this
one is coming off in between the rocks
here got our main cutoff right there
looks like this is failed
so that'll have computer plates at some
point we got this one here oh look keep
a little pecs connector handy and let's
see what's in here
not bad bad at all
hip lova what did Roly Polys let's get
rid of those let's release this flush
everything out stop it and I just try to
cover it up keep the sunlight off of it
help keep it from getting algae too soon
as you can see this follows the path
here all the way down to the lower
cistern and then this is our this area
stays full pretty much all the time if
you had to you could drink it through a
special filtration system we've got one
here that we can actually test out and
try
I'll show you that a little bit later
when we get to little bit warmer
[Applause]
so peaceful back here
so thanks for joining me on my trip
today
off-grid homesteading signing off
[Music]